previously on TV sins we have to get her
off that platform you want me on that
wall you need me on that wall well hello
there who are you
narration in her voice monologue creepy
stalker pontification take your pick
they're all since you're not here to be
over but those bracelets
hey jangle there are so many things I
want to sin about this opening sequence
nearly all of them are related to Joe
turning Beck's clothes and demeanor into
a fantasy about how she wants his sexual
advances rather than play all of them
for you I'll spare you by simply sitting
every bracelet that he says jangle when
they clearly jingle you search the books
fiction F through K that's subtle
you're not the standard insecure nymph
hunting for frog now you'll never finish
speaking of things I'll never finish the
show he kills her he does it I don't
care I cannot handle this guy's internal
cuckoo-bananas talk beyond this damned
episode hello do you work here the man
is wearing an apron and a nametag of
course he works here sad people buy him
folks because of what's popular or not
because they want to be moved or changed
in some way are we forgetting that
sometimes books become popular because
the contents move or change you in some
way like a giving tree man thank you up
he just grabbed Dan Brown's latest on
the way in so he's gonna wander around
for another like 5 or 10 minutes just to
find something legitimate to buy with
him all they're saving Dan Brown's your
kink and be out about it I never thought
I'd hear Dan Brown and kink in the same
sentence but here we are also this
bookstore looks very oddly like a
library there's a goddamn spine label on
this book really I disappointed okay I
personally find them to be disappointing
right at the start of the day but maybe
I'm doing wrong if this was a movie I'd
grab you and we'd go at it right in the
stacks ah yes paint on a stack of
unstable books that jab into your body
and fill the air with book dust this
work TV show that insinuated that was a
good idea uh it's in the out of it metal
aren't I in luck Joe just said a minute
ago he just grabbed Dan Brown's latest
on the way yeah but those are both
paperbacks and there was no universe
where a Dan Brown new release isn't in
hardback only for at least a year
you have enough cash to cover this but
you
want me to know your name or maybe she
only had $20 in cash which is what the
register says her book cost but then it
costs twenty three dollars and twenty
four cents which forced her to use her
credit card is he handing her books back
to her or a sack lunch why is Beck
getting a bag for her books on the guy
who jacks off to Dan Brown just had to
carry them out bagless I was in love
once she broke my heart back oh she
really did a number on me man this shows
going to be all about the inner thoughts
isn't it okay I'll just go ahead and
give Tinson for all the stock oration
I'll have to deal with for the next 40
minutes every account set to public you
want to be seen I am just going to say
this counts as a newspaper column that
repeats itself cliche you folks split
when you were 12
your dad dropped out of the picture I
always thought it was weird that
Facebook had a section for when your
parents got divorced and yes or no
option for if your dad dropped out of
the picture it's Gnostic Jesus it's like
you've never seen a horror movie
or the news Joe would be excellent at TV
sins but also he'd be immediately fired
for being the worst
although Jonathan still has a job here
so maybe Joey would make it is there
some sort of Terminator crossover here
where Beck is secretly a robot with a
high tolerance for piping hot bowls of
microwaved mac and cheese because
there's no way a human could hold this
Jason didn't even get her something that
nice a Nautica finally let him do anal
this show rams the superfluous anal
references into her faces without
permission like it's a goddamn Kingsman
movie it'd be too much even if she did
deserve it which she does not hmm
not all your friends were dumb uh-huh
and you can hear her raspy whisper from
way down the bar how no really look how
far away is
man job seems pretty out in the open
here even if it is dark this street
seems well lit could everything that
happens to bec be avoided if her friends
had better peripheral vision looks good
on you man away
oh he noticed she put on a new shirt
next your weight well ok then when I
suppose this is why we're all okay with
your imminent and irreversible
concussion just in case you want to hate
this masturbating paper let's not forget
he's willing to help the elderly I'll
even do your laundry by pocket your
panties you mean do laundry then good
news you're already doing her laundry
amidst the group text and the merits of
vaginal detoxing I mean it really isn't
anyone's place to tell you what to do
with your vagina and I'm not I'm telling
you to do your research before shoving a
tea bag full of herbs into your house my
wife say it wah wah bah gah gah there's
no place cheaper to live correction no
cheaper place in which you want to live
I never get a Green Point but the things
you do for love right like we're instant
dry shirts and pants because there's no
way those boys are already dry after
getting drenched in the shower is she
thinking open mics are for model slash
singer songwriters slash vegans heavy a
little liar this huh goes down at an
open mic night in New York the ones that
I go to her laid-back and encouraging
there's one southern guy named Ted who
always says you Don good and it's mighty
fine talent you have
so either I've experienced a phenomenon
or this heckling is bull I can't stand
saying this I hate to say this I mean I
really hate say this about a stalker
probable rapist probable murder but I'm
right here with you Joe I'll give all
the sins back if she pukes on him right
now
now what do I do
well I'm a man of my word if you get
this sweep every night
or those are the authors that put you to
sleep and you should find new ones to
read and whatever considers that option
thank you for severing they are pretty
sure you can thank the train tracks for
doing that polyvinyl acetate glue OS I
know this glue this is the convenience
brand that never dries out when left on
the table for indeterminate amounts of
time I would love to meet up to have you
try the goods period that said something
uh I really kind of what joke to kill
the god of this guy so I'm sending the
show for giving me that desire yeah I've
never been texted by the culture guy
from New York magazine but if I were I
would probably look up his information
on the website and Twitter and yes Benji
is painted as an idiot but he's also
greedy and self-centered
I fully believe he would be friending
this Jeff guy and would know that he
either doesn't exist or that Joe here is
not who he says he is oh no not the
artisanal soda engine engine number nine
on the New York transit line if your
girl falls on the track pick her up
there we already have in jokes oh I have
to check on a shipment downstairs okay
and what is stopping anyone from finding
Benji downstairs is there only one
person who takes in shipments repairs
books and keeps up with the collectibles
that's ridiculous
hey weren't all those sins I took away
before go yeah
it's your behavior about my behavior
it's very bad make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it do you like to do it
yourself and your job what do I tell you
always be closing that you call yourself
a Salesman you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
Harriet hurry it's hard hearted
harbinger of haggis last name Roper
god help the poor soul who tried to push
us around
you're talented you're passionate you're
smart
and doggone it people like me